- [Jared] I started making
these maps to have a
beautiful representation of
the places I've traveled:
Yosemite, Zion, Yellowstone,
Rocky Mountain National
Park and many more.
(water splashes)
(upbeat music)
What makes Frank Church Wilderness
unique is just how large it is.
You could fit all of those national parks
within the boundaries of the Frank Church.
- My name is Jared Prince.
I'm the founder of Muir Way
and a designer of artistic maps.
I started making these
maps to have a beautiful
representation of the
places I've traveled.
My maps aren't navigational maps.
They're meant to be hung on your wall,
so that they can inspire on a daily basis.
- The Frank Church is part of the larger
Rocky Mountain range and has
no entry point for humanity.
It has no roads. The
only way to get in is by
airplane or by foot, by
horseback or you have to boat in.
- Usually, when I make a map,
it's of a place that I've already been.
Coors Light has brought
me to the Frank Church,
I'm getting to fly above
the wilderness and just
see all the beautiful
mountains and vistas.
It puts everything in perspective
when you see it from a distance.
- Looking at the map,
now this is so cool to
see it stripped down
and just seeing the raw
contour lines, the topography like that.
This is one of the few
wild places left in America
and it needed to be preserved.
Ah, God, I love this place.
(Country Music)
(plane engine buzzes)
We are now officially at the wilderness.
- [Jared] You can see how
special this place is to Mike.
- This view looking down
the middle fork is one of--
- [Jared] You know it's just as
special to countless other people.
I mean, on the map you
see the contour lines,
so close together, you know
that it's a steep incline.
But then when you see it in real
life, it's just otherworldly.
- [Mike] No matter what direction I look,
it's all completely road-less wilderness.
- [Jared] The geographic
features are the highways.
Instead of a highway, you've got a river.
Instead of street names
you have mountain peaks,
you have valleys, you have creeks.
This is how you get around.
(river babbles)
- [Man] Everything's OK?
- [Jared] Yeah.
(water splashes)
- [Jared] I want to see
how accurate and detailed
this map that I'm creating is.
I want to get the colors
of the place, rivers,
the bends, mountains, the
ruggedness of the wilderness.
That's the essence of a map, is that
it inspires exploration and wonder.
(bee buzzes)
- [Jared] For this map we're going to
donate a portion of the
sales of every map to the
Leave No Trace organization,
which promotes the education
and values of being a
responsible camper in nature.
We can all make a difference
to keep places like this
beautiful, serene and clean
for future generations.
When I look at this Frank
Church map, I'll remember
the river I rafted down
and the piece that I saw in
the airplane, which was
a magical experience.
My hope is that you get
a map for an adventure
that you had and that you get a map
for an adventure that you want to have.
I'm very proud of what I create.
These maps should last a lifetime,
just like memories that were formed there.